let's go to our next caller of course 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 is the number we'll go
to our next caller from the 785 area
code caller what's your name where are
you calling from and what can we do for
you today oh yes hi my name is avi I'm
calling from Kansas City Missouri hey is
this is this the Kansas troll oh no it's
not
he's up in Missouri Kansas City Missouri
oh okay oh I'm sorry okay yeah yeah yeah
all right fair enough good okay so I
just wanted to say the waiting music was
really horrible um but I was wondering
about your coffee I saw your selling
coffee now in coffee mugs we're not
selling coffee mugs but we are selling
coffee okay so um what kind but what
exactly type of blend is this coffee
because I saw Alex Jones is also selling
a coffee it's called Patriot blend and I
was wondering how that's going to be
different with your coffee our coffee
just has nothing to do with Alex Jones
his coffee at all will you be coming out
with the liberal progressive [ __ ] pansy
super female blend with added fluoride
this is the kansas troll I knew it right
when I saw the number I knew that it was
I'm fine keeping him on by the way no
we're not going to have a [ __ ] fluoride
blend no okay
well thanks for taking my car was a real
honor to talk to you pac-man alright
well thank you so much really appreciate
it what a waste of time that's the
kansas troll is it or is it last week or
the week before i saw that a similar
number come up and I asked the caller
are you the Kansas troll and it wasn't
and when we picked up on this guy
immediately I recognized the voice and
that's that's the Kansas troll maybe he
doesn't know he's the Kansas troll well
do you think he's an authentic
conservative hate reott or do you think
he normally agrees with us but just
likes to call and antagonize us anyway I
don't from his voicemails I don't think
he agrees with us okay yeah it's just
it's kind of sad because it's like he
sits on hold and then that's sort of the
best he can do it just doesn't derail
the show it's just like it's just not
funny and um people like to read books
some people like to watch TV others like
to call in and troll talk shows yeah it
was
add in low-energy now all right we'll
listen always a great surprise to and
pleasure to hear from our antagonists
and on that note we will go to a break
we have a classic interview for you this
week back to double calls next week join
us on reddit david pakman.com slash our
EDD IT